[Music]
from the studio that brought you Snow
White Fantasia and the story of
menstruation comes the fairy tale that's
been adapted for film again and again
and again and again and again and again
and again and again and coming soon to a
theater near you again
Cinderella revisit the animated classic
they will cancel out all the empowering
things your daughter learned from frozen
[Music]
where girls are taught to be pushovers
do all the housework and that their
problems will disappear if they're hot
enough to land a rich husband gets swept
away by the tale of Cinderella an orphan
girl enslaved to her step family who's
either a powerful druid that can talk to
animals for years of being locked away
in a castle knitting sweaters for mice
have slowly driven her mad yes I know
it's a lovely movie but it was a lovely
dreamed yep definitely crazy but
everything will change when she meets
her fairy godmother a guardian angel
who's waited years to improve
Cinderella's life in any way instead of
helping her out when her parents died or
winters that family forced her into
slavery thanks for the dress lady but it
would have been more helpful if you
bibbidi bobbidi called Child Protective
Services like eight years ago
even though Cinderella's name is the
title spend more than half the movie
watching a cat trying to contain the
army of vermin who have invested every
corner of the house and for all his
reasonable efforts to continue the road
horde gets bran stark out the window
savor the age-old love story between a
prince who couldn't be bothered to find
his own wife and the king so desperate
for heirs he doesn't care whose uterus
his son uses as a baby factory whether
it's a hermit maid who talks to mice or
just someone with the same shoe size
this slipper may fit any number of
curves that's his problem whatever so
travel back to a simpler time and sing
along to the classic songs you've loved
since childhood
like the song that inspires false hope
[Music]
most dreams just don't come true
but
the rare exception I'm skinny and pretty
and cute
the cute little mice aww
[Music]
and the oscar-nominated jibberish saw
putty blur but derpity derp up Liberty
blabbetty Blanc anything rhymes if you
make up the words salinities Appetit
flippity floppity these readers clearly
were drunk
[Music]
starring I ain't saying she a gold
digger ROM Stoker's Dracula the
Kardashians Wilford Brimley prints foot
fetish Rosie O'Donnell modest mouse and
unrealistic expectations of
relationships that girls carry into
adulthood Sleeping Beauty I know the
stepmom was bad but good luck with the
father-in-law if anything goes wrong be
sure to subscribe for more honest
trailers
thanks to Antonius and AD by for his
help with the awesome music if you want
to see more singing Disney Princesses
click the box below and tell him scream
junkie sent you
President Snow its Katniss can you hear
me
USA USA USA USA I am The Walrus Coco
cashew gentlemen you can't fight in here
this is the war room
scuba smuggled bubble berries fire style
great fire annihilation